irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
nous approchons de bombay
dans ce train jeune couple le frère la
chair la planète viennent de faire un
important périple à travers leur pays
les caisses de bombay fourmille de coûts
voici notre lac où ils sont attendus sur
le quai par leurs parents impatients les
retrouver heureux aussi
ils rentrent chez eux et ils empruntent
les rues de bombay rue grouillante
bordée de palaces de maisons modernes
ils sont attendus par leur grand-mère
vous allez voir le salut respectueux du
petit fils une tasse de thé avant de
raconter le voyage que dessous ni la
maman la grand mère s'apprêtait très
attentive le père est heureux il
souhaitait pour ses enfants une
meilleure connaissance de leurs propres
pays et c'est lille à la jeune fille qui
va nous conter ce qu'elle a vu depuis sa
plus petite enfance elle a toujours été
follement adhérer c'est par la danse
elle c'est avec joie qu'elle a insisté
dans les villages assez dense basé sur
le folklore local
le plupart des danses 1,12 remonte à des
milliers d'années
les costumes sont généralement très
recherché est resplendissante de
couleurs les musiciens jouent des mêmes
instruments qu'on trouve fois la musique
et la danse a peu changé au cours des
siècles
dans celle ci le dieu du mal
symbolise les forces une mauvaise
et
cela c'est le dieu krishna un des dieux
adoré dans l'aisne aujourd'hui
c'est
l'inde est un pays essentiellement
agricole et d'immenses canaux
d'irrigation été creusé pour conduire
l'eau provenant de barrages jusqu'aux
régions agricoles
nos fermiers s'en sert pour arroser ses
flancs dessécher et ainsi améliorer sa
culture
il obtient des cultures un peu plus
abondante on ne peut pas dire que
l'équipement rural soit très très très
moderne même on voit quelques machines
dans la partie centrale nord du pays sur
la rivière jumaa la nouvelle délit
la capitale tels le l'a assisté au
spectacle le plus coloré de leur voyage
la garde présidentielle à cheval
enturbannés beauté et pour n'est
pourtant brillant d'uniformes et culotte
de peau sortant c'est un spectacle
impressionnant
voici taj mahal près de new delhi
c'est un édifice de marbre blanc
il a été érigé à la plus belle histoire
d'amour de lorient
il fut construit par le shâh jahân pour
commémorer la beauté éternelle et le
souvenir de la femme qu'il a aimée et
berdu
tous
puis vers le sud et à l'ouest le long du
gange bénarès la ville sonnent des
hindous à bénarès capitale spirituelle
du monde inde où les fidèles viennent
depuis le commencement des tanches
baigner dans les eaux sacrées du gang
chaque année des milliers de visiteurs
venus de kilomètres à la ronde
vip leur ville sainte et purifie leur
âme dans les eaux du fleuve
le cours du gange est aussi éternel que
sa puissance spirituelle
c'est une rivière de légende de chagrin
de promesses pour ceux qui cherchent son
secret et sa protection
le gang sénat l'inde étrange insondable
toujours fascinante attirant l'esprit
des fidèles
au cours des nombreux kilomètres
parcourus ils ont vu beaucoup d'animaux
sauvages des jaguars les centaines et
des centaines de sage et
l'extraordinaire pangolin couvert des
cayes protectrice comme une armure
quant au but il semble paisible et se
baignent tranquillement dans les étangs
pendant la chaleur du jour est bien
entendu l'éléphant
celui ci est sculpté dans l'ivoire
travail de patience d'adressent broderie
la basse est aussi un art
au cours de leur voyage ils sont allés
chez un de leurs cousins qui se mariait
ils ont été bien entendu invités à la
cérémonie
voici la voiture des jeunes mariés
couverte de guirlandes de fleurs et la
robe de la jeune cousine était un
héritage transmis de mère en fille à
l'héritage de très très grande valeur
l'endroit où le mariage avait lieu
s'appelle le v10 ici les mariés reste
assis pendant une grande partie de la
cérémonie qui quelquefois dure trois
jours
ils se tiennent par la main pendant la
cérémonie tandis que les offrandes sont
faites au feu considéré comme le témoin
du mariage
les mariés font cette fois le tour de la
flamme en prenant à chaque fois des
engagements solennels
puis le par aux ide lit les versets du
vieux livres de mariage en inde où est
une île et marié dans les liens sacrés
du mariage
les membres de la famille se tiennent
les mains et du lait est versée pour
signifier que la jeune fille de la
maison par a jamais état de mysore dans
la partie centrale du sud du pays
c'est là que se trouve la statue de
ravanne le dieu du mal que rama le dieu
du bien qu'on bâtit et terrasses à nandy
le taureau sacré des indes où il faut
passer sous sa patte qu'un indice
appelle aussi le protecteur et ceux qui
passent sous sa patte son protégé du mal
il faut aussi goûté la nourriture sainte
et déposer une fleur au pied de nez n'dy
en signe de respect et le palais du
maharadjah de misère cet édifice est
maintenant au musée de reliques venus de
l'inde tout entière c'est là que se
déroule la cérémonie de sa serre fait
par laquelle on célèbre la victoire de
ram assure le démo ravanne symbole de la
victoire du bien sur le mal
le maharajah est hélas il portait une
robe brillante spécialement réalisé pour
cette occasion
les éléphants été somptueusement paraît
et en sa qualité de gouverneur de mysore
le maharajah est aussi le chef religieux
investi des fonctions sacerdotales
il bénit les animaux les éléphants les
vaches sacrées il leur jettent des
fleurs dans un geste symbolique tous les
cas roche sont aussi béni avant qu'il ne
prenne part à la procession la cavalerie
et les forces de l'état de misère des
filles en grand uniforme
et voici les gardes du corps montés sur
leurs chameaux les éléphants
magnifiquement paraît lourd marche en
fin de parole et s'étend palanquin que
le maharajah rejoint sa suite à travers
les rues de la ville encombrer le soir
tombe la fête s'achèvera dans la nuit au
milieu des lumières ainsi que je voyais
art
irène chagnaud vous a proposé voyagera
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec le concours de caltech c'est le
challenge péters sont luc pv ni montage
pierre michel rey illustration sonore
denise laser